Wenn Sie tagelang, wochenlang versuchen,
in ein System einzudringen [und] das klappt
nicht, ist das frustrierend.
Aber wenn Sie‘s dann schaffen,
ist das ein unglaublicher Kick.
Ein unglaublicher Kick
ist auch dieses Interview.
Ich spreche mit „Lukas“.
Das ist nicht sein echter Name,
und sein Gesicht zeigen dürfen wir auch
nicht, denn seine Arbeit ist streng geheim.
Lukas ist Cyberspion
beim Bundesnachrichtendienst,
dem deutschen Geheimdienst fürs Ausland.
Das darf aber niemand wissen und
entsprechend läuft unser Treffen auch ab.
Wir dürfen kaum etwas filmen:
nicht, wie wir unsere Handys wegschließen,
nicht, wie wir durch
die Sicherheitsschleusen gehen.
Lukas treffen wir schließlich
in einem abgelegenen Raum.
Die ganze Zeit hinter der Kamera:
der Pressesprecher
und ein Sicherheitsbeauftragter.
Was genau machen Sie?
Was genau ich tue, kann ich im Detail
natürlich jetzt nicht verraten.
Aber im Prinzip gesagt: Ich bin Hacker.
Das heißt, ich dringe in IT-Systeme ein,
um Informationen zu beschaffen.
Klassische Sachen wären, dass man andere
Länder aufklärt, zum Beispiel:
Man interessiert sich dafür,
was im Land X oder Y passiert.
Eine andere Variante wäre, man will wissen:
Was ist mit Waffen- und Wehrtechnik
im Ausland?
Was ist mit organisierter Kriminalität?
Dann natürlich, was immer gut geht:
Was ist mit Terrorismus?
Das sind natürlich alles Felder,
wo auch Hacking in irgendeiner Art und
Weise ausgeprägt gefragt ist.
Lukas sagt das,
als wäre es das Alltäglichste der Welt.
Er ist um die 30 Jahre alt – so viel verrät er.
Das Hacken hat er sich selbst beigebracht.
Per Initiativbewerbung
kam er vor einigen Jahren zum BND
und macht seitdem einen Job,
von dem er niemandem etwas erzählen darf.
Meistens sage ich, ich mache die IT
in irgendeinem Amt, das ich dann vorschiebe.
Und dann fragen die meisten
auch schon gar nicht mehr nach,
weil das klingt wie Drucker einrichten
und das interessiert niemanden.
Egal wo auf der Welt: Zu jeder Zeit schlägt
ein Schmetterling mit seinen Flügeln.
Und es kann etwas entstehen,
was für uns eine Bedeutung hat.
Der BND sucht dringend nach Leuten,
die mit IT-Systemen
noch geschickter umgehen können
als der klassische Informatiker.
Mit solchen PR-Filmen will er sein Image als
Arbeitgeber aufpolieren.
Der Nachrichtendienst steht dabei in harter
Konkurrenz zur Privatwirtschaft.
Dort können die Kandidaten
deutlich mehr verdienen.
Das weiß auch der Pressesprecher.
Auf den ersten Blick
ist das ein klarer Wettbewerbsnachteil
für den Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Aber auch der Bundesnachrichtendienst
versucht, ein attraktiver Arbeitgeber zu sein.
Klar sagt der Sprecher das.
Aber was sagt Lukas? Warum ist er hier?
Weil ich hier die Dinge tun kann,
die ich a) draußen so nicht legal tun kann
und b) hat man schon den Eindruck,
dass man etwas getan hat,
und am Ende geht es in die Berichterstattung
ein, das hat irgendetwas verändert.
Es hat eben nicht einfach nur bei irgendeiner
Firma irgendwo einen Haken gesetzt
bei „Wir haben einen
Sicherheitstest gemacht“,
sondern es hat eine
außenpolitische Konsequenz gehabt.
Und das ist ein Output, den finde ich gut und
da nehme ich auch weniger Geld in Kauf
– zumal ich jetzt auch nicht tot umfalle von
dem Gehalt, das ich verdiene.
Woanders zu arbeiten, das könne er sich
zumindest im Moment nicht vorstellen.
Und als Beamter muss er das auch nicht.
Es sei denn, seine Tarnung fliegt auf.
Mein privates Umfeld weiß
im engeren Umkreis,
nähere Verwandtschaft, wo ich arbeite.
Bestimmte einzelne Freunde wissen auch,
wo ich arbeite.
Aber darüber hinaus habe ich bisher auch
immer nur die Resonanz bekommen:
Okay, du arbeitest beim BND, ich weiß,
du kannst nichts dazu sagen.
Und damit ist die Sache erledigt.
Zu Hause nie über Erfolge oder Frust
im Job sprechen? Wie geht das?
Es ist in der Tat schwierig, zu Hause gar nicht
über die Arbeit reden zu können, inhaltlich.
Das wusste ich vorher.
Das macht‘s nicht einfacher, natürlich,
aber ich kann damit leben.
Und da es bei mir der Fall ist, dass ich mit
zwei, drei Kollegen sehr gut befreundet bin,
kann ich im Zweifel auch mal
in die Büros gehen
und da mich ... auskotzen,
wie man so sagt.
Es ist schon faszinierend,
diese Vorstellung, ein Doppelleben zu führen,
Dinge zu wissen,
die die Öffentlichkeit
vielleicht nie erfahren wird.
Ein bisschen konnte ich spüren, wie das ist.
Aber habe ich etwas wirklich
Überraschendes gesehen?
Nein.
Der BND ist ein Geheimdienst,
und der sorgt schon dafür,
dass das, was hinter diesen Mauern passiert,
vor allem eines bleibt: geheim.